hey martin how's it going
hey abby well i'm having a european wine
party with a group of friends soon
and we each want to buy a vintage wine
from a small wine store in paris
the website shows how many euros it is
but it doesn't convert to us dollars
you know i think we could build you a
new tool with python that will save you
and your friends some conversion time
i'll show you how
[Music]
python is one of the most popular
programming languages and growing
it's well suited for a number of use
cases including web applications
machine learning and big data cloudround
lets you use
any runtime you want making it easy to
deploy python in a serverless way
cloudrun is also fully managed meaning
you don't have to worry about
infrastructure scaling if your server
starts getting a ton of traffic
that sounds awesome uh do i have to
change my python code to get it to run
on cloud run
if you have an existing stateless python
app all you need to do is add
one file to deploy a service to cloud
run no code changes needed
we like to use flask for small services
like this because it's a lightweight
framework that's easy to set up
our service has the basics an html file
where we create a form to get user input
a simple css file and an app.pi file
where we set routes
and define functions okay that looks
exactly like the web apps i've built
before
what is that extra file i need for cloud
run
the last file we need to define is the
docker file this allows us to customize
the runtime of our container to suit our
needs exactly
containers are a way to isolate our
application to make it run the same no
matter where it's deployed
when creating a docker file we first
need to specify a base docker image
with the from command this is where we
set our python runtime
the copy command adds files from your
docker client's current directory
the run command installs flask g unicorn
and currency converter dependencies for
our service
and finally cmd is the command to start
our application
inside the container and binds it to a
port the app app at the end means
import our app from the app.pi file
what if i want to use a different
version of python
one of the advantages of cloud run is
that you can run any python version you
want
as long as there is a base docker image
available for it i can even use the
newest version of python
version 3.8 if i want to now that we
have our docker file we can build our
container with cloud build
this bundles up our code along with
everything we've added in our docker
file
and pushes it to the container registry
a place to start container images
and finally we deploy the surface to
cloud run
it only takes two commands to get this
service out to the world
in our terminal we first build the
container using the builds command
and then we deploy the service using the
container image we just built
if we check out the cloud run section of
google cloud console
we now see our cloud run service if we
click the service
we can see important info like metrics
and the url of our service
we can also redirect or split user
traffic to previous revisions if we
discover
our latest revision has a breaking
change wow this sounds great
let me test it out oh
wait i think i'm doing something wrong
i'm being taken to an
error page how can i find out what's
going on
that's where cloud monitoring comes to
the rescue everything that happens
within this service is logged in cloud
monitoring
including errors you can see the logs of
our service from the cloud monitoring
powered logs tab
i think this is showing a little too
much info though if i head to the
metrics tab
i can see the latest errors filtering
out all the other noise
let's take a look looks like
an error value was triggered on line
20. ah i didn't account for submitting
an empty string
let's fix that build and deploy one more
time
ah that should do the trick awesome
looks like it's not working
let me see how much this wine is going
to cost me
oh i think i need to take some money out
of my savings account
oh no i'm sure it'll be worth it though
but anyways thanks i can't wait to share
this service with my friends
i think it'll come in handy if you want
to check out the code for this video
look in the description below
until next time
you